[Music]
this is line everyone's talking about
maniac and bad Brainiac in her head
[Music]
how did Nick react the first time she
heard it I think she liked it do you
think wasn't it cool here with you when
you wrote it that's why I got so
intimate I was missing her maybe after
nearly 12 years of marriage keep inacol
still know how to keep things hot and it
involves a lot of singing together we
hear Nicole elsewhere on your album on
the song female background vocals
as my idea she was hot and and I thought
that's a very that's a powerful song
especially as the father loved girls as
well she just joined you on stage
recently it was a great moment I was
talking about parallel line actually the
song and from the back of the room I had
this voice
play this song so I suddenly thought oh
you come up here and sing it which I
never thought she would
I think she'll never heckle me the
country crooner from New Zealand is
getting ready to hit the road again he
told us the couple's two daughters
seven-year-old faith and nine-year-old
Sunday loved being on the tour bus with
him but they'll definitely be home for
Mother's Day what is that day like in
your house
just making sure Nick feels all the love
do you have any surprises planned this
year I hope it's all a surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]